[Music]
in porn ban News submitted by yeap what
does that mean expressive turn it was
like a slang word they used it for a
bunch of stuff it could mean like it
could mean like you're faking somebody
out like oh yeah oh really
yeah it means different it's like the
new psyche it's not it's not current
anymore when you're hyped about
something or you know these or these two
do sit like this they'd be like like
yeah don't tell nobody tumblr
no the Wayans brothers John Witherspoon
tumblr is banning all adult content from
its platform yo I heard about this I
don't even know there was porn on tumblr
there's a lot of product how did you not
know from my back in the day when it was
popping I would post my videos there but
I didn't know it was used for porn
turned into a porn site really yeah
some blur somebody was one of like I
mean I used to be on tumblr a lot I
recently just deleted my whole tumblr
but tumblr used to be a very like you
could go you nothing was censored on
there and I'm saying it was very jack
worthy it was Jack worthy there was some
Jack worthy [ __ ] but also the thing
about tumblr is that like people posted
very you know like artsy nudes and [ __ ]
aerated the poor like the post a video
and they write an essay on what they
liked about it I mean there was that too
but then I was like it was like regular
ass porn and they're like and give
what's regular porn to you oh no I mean
I mean everything's regular to me
because I watch some weird [ __ ] but but
there's like very cool like like there
was porn gifts you know I'm saying which
were hot and that's basically what Tom
birds for I thought was porn gifts no I
mean yeah I mean there was cool [ __ ] was
I'm gonna disappear because I gotta hop
on this this [ __ ] tumblr porn train
before it okay so it says here starting
December 17th adult content will not be
allowed on tumblr regardless of how old
you are which is crazy December 17 yes
so soon are
why that's Pacific date good question
holidays I guess everyone's in town
they're like you know probably tumblr
guy whoever is head of tumblr he's
probably like wait a minute okay my kids
are gonna be in town PI R on December
17th he's like so that'll be good for me
to like stop this porn break that I need
are they trying to rebrand tumblr so
they could get more followers because I
don't think that's the way to go I heard
it's because that their um their app got
taken off the App Store yeah is they had
they got caught with like some of their
something people flaming kid porn and
stuff like this
why can't Google Chrome get taken off
the App Store - or you yeah what what a
joke man that's what I don't get about
this there's also I mean you can find
mad point on Twitter like Twitter
doesn't really like delete Google Images
search for pictures of my wife you'll
see dicks in her mouth Twitter is [ __ ]
wild I saw a clip that I scrolled by and
I didn't understand why I had so many
likes because you just like look like a
bunch of people around a girl that's
whatever I went back to it and it was a
girl taking a shot out of a guy's
foreskins guy whipped out his dick he
extends his foreskin somebody pours a
shot in it and then she drinks out of it
I was like that's the thing it's like
you can twist kind of like you can find
anything on like twitter is kind of like
the moat like the most like [ __ ] up
app right now so me too man you still
like Twitter men do Twitter Twitter's
probably like the most only I like it
better than Instagram oh no so the old
people on insta now and I'm one of them
it still poppin yeah but Twitter you can
do so much there's so much engagement
yeah you know there's pictures as video
conversation conversations like there's
a lot you can do on Twitter that that
people kind of don't like know what
people do now I'm sorta one time when I
saw a girl using her boyfriend's
testicles as a Beautyblender
Oh
Challenge almost have been shot that
from a powder
yeah like dab didn't like and then they
just like to smooth out the makeup and
we did a JK article about that
yeah we did that the thing about twenty
act it remembers is that she's not here
though the constant is even if you don't
follow someone right like let's say if I
fall a twin but pretend but then he
likes something or someone that he like
it pops up on my feet so one time I'm
just looking and then there's a girl
riding somebody's dick and I'm like I
didn't follow that just a girl riding
double dick I demand an explanation
I know shout out to Ricky shucks I don't
know I've never ever seen porn before
and go ruffle shirt use a little more
right and that's like my mom was in the
room like somebody's in the room that no
no this is it what is this do your
family doesn't follow any of the things
that you do like online or anything like
that yeah yeah they've like follow your
career up until this point like I feel
like they've gotten an inkling of have
you ever showed them your pranks are you
like social experiments at all yeah well
my so here's the thing my dad loves the
[ __ ] right awesome he can't like good
admitted his money and then my mom like
hates it right because she has no
comedic taste
she's like Oh Stephen Oh a Red Skelton
if you watch the Red Skelton Christmas
special and I'm like you mean the guy
from the 1950's girl like it's nuts so
this is involve you know the clown
character right yeah right I know about
that white people I don't even know
she still want you to be like this
wholesome boy like preserve your boy
miss every time I call her and I say
that I'm working on movie I guys
recently talking about our movie about
the orgy no no okay exactly because if I
do cuz my hogs are goes just Steven oh
just make sure that it's not it's not
that bad seems like people just need
nice things now Steven they don't need
all this all this dower the dark and
especially stuff that's a sweet the
wholesomeness have never heard anybody
you know my mother on me yeah my mom
laughs in tears really she watches all
of our [ __ ] you know she watches your
videos oh yeah she watches oh they don't
do [ __ ] but watch YouTube all day long
and when they're done with that she
tells me she goes on Facebook sees if
we're updating [ __ ] Instagram all that
[ __ ] dude she's like an obsessed fan
she's a fan I'm gonna say my dad like my
dad usually loves all my [ __ ] too but he
recently watched the video and he was
like just your kind of vulgar you're too
vulgar and I said which one what that's
the thing okay so my dad usually down
for all the dick jokes everything all
the cuss word he's dope I love your dad
oh yeah man that's the [ __ ] right but
there was a video I used a euphemism
that he didn't understand so I was
talking this girl and I was like yeah so
you don't want to be all nice like you
know like sucking his dick or then I
look at her that will suck in your [ __ ]
you know I'm saying yeah my dad thought
I was like literally being graphic
talking about her suck in some day oh no
no that you know in a sense I was I was
saying not to you know suck up some too
much that's it be like you know like
[ __ ] he's like oh okay he's already
ready to beat it down but he's like no
this one my mom's cut off my dick get
off my dick okay your old man came up to
me at your wedding and and he's like oh
man you burned the [ __ ] out of my son at
the rose
that's what he knows you you know his
boy okay I'm so sorry
we're meeting spicy food damn that is
awesome oh my dad yeah it does an
interesting man did you definitely get
your sexual humor from your dad it's
like it's not like you're the the
[ __ ] weird pervert it's more like
it's a family trait well here's the I'm
not a family trait it's a tie people
trained because like people ask me all
the time like you know how does your
family deal with you talking about dicks
and like coochies all the time I'm like
guys where do you think I got it from I
grew up around old Thai people
constantly making like vagina jokes and
penis jokes like whenever my mom would
make like like seafood at the restaurant
like like oysters and [ __ ] it was always
like oh you know all yours looks like
this looks like that when like it was
always just like dirty jokes and Thai
people overall I don't want to
generalize because I'm sure some people
don't eat just your family your mom so
cool that she orders fans like dude that
was super only a surprise though because
when I was when I was in Thailand right
we went to the night market yeah and
there are several stores that were
selling happy dicks like there were
wooden carvings of happy dicks just
[ __ ] with a [ __ ] uh The Dictator
or whatever yes dude I feel like that's
like a Filipino thing too because they
had the barrel man oh yeah so it's like
it's just due to pull down a fat dick
pops
first of all I saw that was in Thailand
wait no we explained boy okay okay so
it's a wooden it's a wooden wooden guy
with a wooden barrel on its own toy okay
and then you lift them for the guy you
mix the barrel like up or down and as
soon as the barrel comes down a big old
wooden thing oh yeah so I feel like an
even like you Filipino cultures they
always talked about sex whatever what
yeah and that's what my friend's dad
came up to me and he was like hey maybe
you don't like booze bus like what about
[ __ ] that are like [ __ ] because I
were to bring a girl around he goes if
you don't like are you gay
and as I have you seen my dick statue
watch this it comes out with the barrel
watch this that's what I love though is
that cuz I've been to we were in Bali
and they have like you could buy like
big dick statues and [ __ ] good in people
you know the guys think it's funny the
vendors like hey hey hey like the whole
time and it's like you're talking about
like in the Philippines it's like this
[ __ ] and then over here its dick jokes
is like a currency like Tim Tim you
bought you're paid your parents mortgage
from dick Jones ik and Koo Chi Joe true
it's very true there's a Japanese anime
for children called Shin Chon I think
it's getting popular here but they edit
out the dick jokes because sometimes so
just like you know how kids run around
with just a t-shirt on around the house
and you see this little [ __ ] dick
hanging out and he likes to flash people
and [ __ ] and that's that's okay like
kids watch that cartoon all the way all
the time over there and you see the
little [ __ ] baby dick running around
yeah yeah so it's I don't know it's not
a big deal maybe it's like new to these
a big big deal looks like Chinese porn
where you can see the dick you see
everything but it's like got that little
tiny blue tiniest bit of pixelation you
could ever have but it's like it's like
you walked up to a window and you went
like this look the time smallest bit
it's like and it's not you know what the
funny thing it's so [ __ ] hairy you
don't even need the pixelation
it's hiding either way I'm like hiding -
hair yeah it just looks like a wise man
with the weird nose coming out no
Japanese girls are pretty pubes it's
been a while dude well because all
cultures are not my favorite no I say
you know what some started shaving
nowadays oh no it's the type you get is
it back now it's I was gonna say will me
and Rick discuss I have been discussing
for a long time how like we don't we
like we like we kind of like some Bush
and Bush Bush is kind of made the made a
comeback of recent years like which is
kind of like on like the on the return
you're like eating out vagina with Bush
on it well that's the thing it's like
the actual bush in on the actual part
that you like Blake and said it's above
it could be like like some you know as
long as it's like you know it's Pleasant
and all just kept very well-kept
capped is better but it's just not when
I see it I just go like a because what
I'm talking about it just looks like a
backyard that hasn't been touched
yeah it's just everywhere yeah you know
what I mean it was my parents backyard
okay man if a girl wants to be bushing
I'm down for the bush too bro I mean I
you know that's nice yeah but if it has
like a rusty old bike laying down in the
middle of it it's cozy
you don't say it's like wintertimes
[Music]